(dramatic music)
- Elon Musk is expected to
testify in a federal trial
that deals with tweets he sent in 2018,
regarding the possibility
of taking Tesla private.
Elon Musk tweeted, "Am
considering taking Tesla private
at 420, funding secured."
He later followed up saying,
Investor support is confirmed.
Only reason why this is not certain
is that it's contingent
on a shareholder vote."
Tesla's stock price closed up about 11%
the day that Mr. Musk sent those tweets,
and it later gave back those
gains and fell further.
- Thank you all for
coming tonight, and I...
- The deal which would've been valued
at around $72 billion never materialized.
The plaintiff has alleged
that Mr. Musk's tweets
were false material to investors
who relied upon them to
make trading decisions,
and that this class of investors
lost billions of dollars as a result.
Attorneys presented opening statements
on January 18th, in the case.
An attorney for the defendants
who include Mr. Musk,
Tesla, and members of
the board at the time
described the tweets as,
'Shorthand, made in the heat of the moment
that didn't differ materially
from the situation at hand, even though,
in some cases, they may have
been technically inaccurate."
(audience applauding)
The plaintiff is seeking damages
for investor losses
that Musk's tweets allegedly caused.
The plaintiff said in a trial brief,
"As a result of the turmoil
and the prices for Tesla
stock, options, and bonds
caused by Musk in Tesla's statements,
investors lost billions of dollars
from August 7th, 2018
to August 17th, 2018.
The judge in this case has already ruled
that certain of Musk's
statements were untrue.
That means that the key
questions left for the jury
include whether those statements
were material to investors,
and whether Musk knew
that they were untrue.
Musk is expected to testify
as soon as January 20th.
The witness lists indicate
that we may get to hear
from Tesla executives
and current and former board members
about what was going on inside the company
at this incredibly interesting,
chaotic time at Tesla.
The trial is expected to
run for about three weeks,
through the beginning of February,
before being turned over to
the jury to decide the verdict.
(tranquil music)